[Musique]
bonsoir bon froid
je veux patron ou là j'oubliais mon le
cheval voilà ça cassait d'être trop
pressés des calmes nounours vous avez
raison du calme nounours bah
shuttle
est
du cas une bourse
[Musique]
coucou c'est loulou
madame à prônes el
menzah
[Musique]
excellente idée marcheurs mais où est-on
monsieur nicolas
si mes amis
aux routes
[Musique]
sur le pont d'avignon
géré le pont d'avignon
dans ceux du temps sur le pont d'avignon
pour andy dans ce doux soro
[Musique]
je me plante albi non on dit dans ce
petit dans ce bottin inclus dont on dit
dans ce domaine
[Musique]
sur le ton de vie non on est dans ce
taudis danse sur le pont vino conduite
ans tous en rond
[Musique]
à
haro monsieur nono avant au col pro ben
oui fait chaud avignon et bien belles
dames éprouvé cieux où les allées
[Musique]
oh mais les belles dames ne dorment pas
avec leur collier qui a raison mangoné
nov
non juste un liner
bonne une
bonne nuit n'est celle militaire bonne
nuit et ce talent
[Musique]
connaissez-vous le pont d'avignon patron
non nounours je ne connais pas vous avez
peur c'est un pont formidable et on s'y
amuse
vive le pont d'avignon et bien vive le
pont d'avignon bonne nuit les enfants
fait pour eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
oui
[Musique]